good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I
must say this is a tremendous pleasure
it's an owner also to be here with you
and over the last four decades I had the
privilege of speaking at many
universities in North America South
America and the Middle East in Europe
and Asia but few can compare with
Stanford either in terms of its
reputation or its positive and lasting
impact on the world and just before I
proceed I have a message from someone in
Saudi Arabia to the University here as
you know many of our employees are
Stanford graduates we are very happy
with that and one of them asked me to
pass this message to you and he asked
that I wish the Cardinal the best luck
in the big game coming up against Carla
and he he said that he is looking
forward to a repeat of last year result
so I hope I have delivered the message
this is a unique time for me both as
president and CEO of Saudi Aramco and as
an individual this year
mr. humanly just mentioned that we
celebrated our 75th anniversary with the
theme of energy for generations and this
is a reference not only to the
generations of men and women who built
our company over the years but also the
fact that we will continue to reliably
supply energy to the four corners of the
world for many generations to come
the anniversary provided us with an
opportunity to look back on our proud
history as well as to our future as an
organization and as such it was a time
for both introspection and for
purposeful action I would note that this
part of the world holds a special place
in our story and my thunder was stolen
because actually the company that signed
the 1933 saw such an agreement with the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia was Standard Oil
of California predecessor of the Chevron
and as you know it's based was based up
the road in San Francisco
Mike's tiny keys test stays and becomes
in our history in the center of in our
exhibit centre at the heart of that
Center we have a huge picture of Mike's
tiny key graduate of this University his
gear his books it's put there people ask
us you know
you are a Saudi company why do you have
in the center of your of your exhibit is
a reference to to do your American
connection and we say we are very proud
of our American connection and this is
really what made us what we are is this
is this connection so it's coming here
is like coming home or our ancestral
home for many of my myself and my
friends from a personal perspective I
will be retiring at the end of this year
after for four full decades of service
with Saudi around who are nearly 14
years as its president and CEO this is a
special moment for me to look back on my
career as an oilman and an executive
from this vantage point I can view my
accomplishments with a sense of
achievement look at my mistakes and the
occasional missed opportunity with a
tinge of regret and regards the lessons
I have learned with an appreciation for
the knowledge and wisdom they imported
most of all I can appreciate the
friendships that I have formed with so
many outstanding individuals in the
world of energy and beyond I have been
truly blessed in my career and in my
management team and I leave knowing that
the company is in a safe strong pair of
hands and the person of my successor mr.
Harlan Fowler currently our executive
vice president for operations and an
outstanding leader in his own right even
though he's a Texas A&M Aggies by the
way I was trying to compose my thoughts
for this session on the importance of
leaders and leadership in the world of
business and the key success factors
that set truly outstanding business men
and women apart from the great and the
good and I was
by a passage in the mission statement of
Stanford Graduate School of Business
which says the school will and quote
develop innovative principled and
insightful leaders who change the world
and quote to me those words encompass a
universe of possibilities and promise
and so I would like to look at the
concept of innovation inside and
principle and examine how living those
values truly can change the world
innovation is near and dear to my heart
in fact I have made innovation the
watchword of my tenure as president of
Saudi Aramco early in the years when I
became president I was asked what would
I would what would I Whitby want to be
known for at the time of my retirement
and my answer maybe it was the second
year when I took the job I said I want
to be known as the one who led the
journey out of the bottle and what that
meant is into encouraging and capturing
the ideas and initiatives of our people
and then apply them to our work and our
operations as you know we managed
roughly 1/5 of the planet's proven
reserves of crude oil and supply about
one in every 10 barrels of oil that the
world population consumes every day and
so there's a lot - there's a lot on our
ability to deliver is a lot of riding or
we will hit deliver and the brain power
of our people constitutes the single
most
tant factor in fulfilling that
responsibility and is without a doubt
one of our greatest competitive
advantages as an organization thanks to
an institution as great as this one
today our employees are contributing
fresh and exciting ideas in many
different facets of our business
including the development of new
technology and improved tools
streamlined operational processes and a
new revenue streams and cost-saving
initiatives whether these innovations
are revolutionary step changes that
transform our business or incremental
improvements and enhancements they are
all important in helping us maintain
Saudi Aramco status as the single most
reliable supplier of vital energy to
Saudi Arabia and the wider world
when prerequisite for such an
environment of innovation and engagement
is developing and sustaining a culture
of creativity and self-development in
which people at all levels of the
business are encouraged to challenge or
change outdated modes of thinking and to
manage their own careers and assume
responsibility for their own
professional development to a large
extent the tone is set by an
organization's leadership team who must
themselves question their own
assumptions be prepared to step out of
their own comfort zones and take
calculated and well-informed risks
recognizing that they are risks all the
same and contain not only the seeds of
success but also the possibility of
failure
but more important than lofty token
high-level discussions are concrete
applications which nurture and sustain
such a culture for example at Saudi
Aramco we utilize a whole range of
self-sustaining programs which cultivate
the intellect and hone the talents of
our people these include and extensive
offerings of online learning courses in
many different fields structured
individual development plans and the
performance management program for
uniform employee evaluation and
development cafe style conferences which
bring employees together to discuss
pressing issues and recognition programs
to highlight those men and women
throughout the company who have created
and spearheaded innovative programs and
initiatives yet as the Chinese say and I
just came from China talk doesn't boil
the rice
and even those programs are wasted
unless the intellectual energy they
unleash can be harnessed and an
innovative idea ter and into an
innovative application it's like the
waters of a rushing stream or a river
it's only when you build a waterwheel to
turn a millstone that you have converted
the energy of the current into
beneficial effort perhaps the most
significant step we have taken in that
regard is our idea management system
which lets employees electronically
submit ideas and suggestions to the
responsible Organization for evaluation
and where applicable implementation but
if innovation is the motor that keeps an
organization moving toward through both
choppy is seized and still then insight
is the ability to look all around and
make sense of those waters charting
dangerous rocks and reefs and
identifying where the passage will be
smoothest when it comes to insight I see
four areas which are important for a
successful executive and indispensable
for a true industry leader
the first is knowing what you get to do
in your company or what you get paid to
do in your company of course that sounds
ridiculous but perhaps the most frequent
railing of executives who rise up
through their organizations is staying
in jail engaged in my node details and
relatively lower level issues in other
words keeping the keys to the workshop
the house or the sales room
your pocket even after you have been
given the swipe card to the executive
suite in my case I don't need to know
every detail about how our real-time
remote drilling systems work or what
kind of catalyst we are using in our
refineries or whether preventive
maintenance has been carried out on a
specific pump in any of our large plants
there are other people who get paid to
take care of those things and they do it
much better than I ever could in a
company like Saudi Aramco we have
hundreds of professional disciplines
hard at work every day a CEO I don't
need to know how they do their work but
when I need to know is how to enable
them to work together to ensure we meet
our commitments as a company that's what
I and my management team get paid to do
second top notch executives use their
time to stay engaged in their industries
they stay abreast of trends in the
market and developments in technology
they know who their competitors and
counterparts are and what strategies
they are pursuing and they seek out
mentors among experienced leaders in
their area of business by studying their
industry and engaging with others and
the same field sharp executives not only
enhance their own professional attitude
and the performance of their
organizations but also create a network
of contacts which stand them in good
stead throughout their careers third
it's essential that business leaders
gain a high degree of comfort in
transcending generational and
particularly cultural boundaries
given the increasingly globalized nature
of business this level of confidence is
essential for leaders of companies both
large and small
even if yours is a local or regional
business and not a major multinational
it's highly likely that both your
workforce and your customer base are
multicultural and multi-ethnic in nature
cross-cultural understanding is is
imperative actually at Saudi Aramco
people of many different nationalities
have worked side-by-side since the
earliest time of the company and
multiculturalism is hardwired in our
corporate DNA although we are a
state-owned Saudi company the official
language of our business has always been
English and we send students every year
to Japanese Korean Chinese universities
to end the degrees by studying in those
languages and today we have nearly 60
different nationalities represented in
our workforce and if by any chance you
drop by our headquarters dining hall at
lunch you will hear not only Saudi
Arabic and drawls from the Texas oil
patch but also Spanish French Tagalog
Hindi and a half-dozen other languages
for me that's a source of pride and yet
another competitive advantage for my
company because I know we can do
business anywhere in the world and feel
at home
personally I am fascinated by the
societies and traditions of other lands
and have benefited as a businessman by
taking arduous hikes in Korea visiting
ancient Japanese temples prowling
fragrant spice markets in India
and journeying the through the lush
Brazilian rainforest at the same time
I'm proud to be an Arab and seek to
share my culture and interpret my
heritage to others just as I study and
sample theirs and Mahatma Gandhi
beautifully put it he said I want the
cultures of all lands to be blown about
my house as freely as possible but I
refuse to be blown off my feet by any
fourth I think it is important to
nourish your own innate intellectual
curiosity these outside interests might
be a passion for the visual arts or
music appetite for great literature and
poetry keeping up to speed with the
latest developments in science and
technology even first-time sports as
participant or fan personally I am a
voracious reader of world literature and
current events titles I love Italian and
German opera and the classic and modern
Arabic music and of course there is
nothing that can match playing with my
two granddaughters these things have
sustained me throughout my time a CEO at
Saudi Aramco because they are very very
enriching whatever inspires and informs
you should continue to be a part of your
regimen as you progress in the world of
business because the rewards will remain
with you long after the next quarterly
performance review or annual board
meeting ladies and gentlemen I said
earlier that innovation is the motor
which powers our company's progress and
inside enables us to make sense of the
environment around us but neither is
complete without the third
in the Graduate School of business's
mission statement and that is a
principle this is the guiding light by
which we must steer our ship and chart
the course of our company
I believe principle underlies both of
the others and in its absence we may do
the job right but still not do the right
job to my mind the principle in business
comes down to simply this identify your
responsibilities as an organization or a
company and make only those commitments
that you are confident you can keep in
an ethical manner the issue of defining
your organization's responsibilities is
one that fascinates me and which has
played an important role in my time as
head of Saudi Aramco I would like to
share with you the way we view our
purpose as a company we have identified
three key areas of responsibility or
basic principles for Saudi Aramco which
has given rise to what we call the
tripod concept and these are first our
responsibility to keeping global
petroleum markets reliably supplied
being of course the world's largest
producer and exporter of crude oil and
the fact that we are the only company
that is a main supplier to all three
major global market regions we are the
number one supplier of crude oil to
economies like China India Japan and
Korea and a major provider of petroleum
to Europe and the United States as such
a large chunk of the global economy is
running on our crude oil production
second we have a responsibility for the
economic development of Saudi Arabia and
the prosperity of its society which we
fulfill not only through revenue
generation but also by providing
petroleum products to the local market
supplying natural gas to industries and
utilities across the country including
the kingdom's massive gas based
petrochemical industry and through the
goods and services we procure from the
Saudi private sector I would also
include our far-reaching corporate
social responsibility programs and
knowledge sharing initiatives in this
category because of the profound
positive effect they have had in local
communities and companies and third
there is our responsibility to our
shareholder the Saudi government to
conduct our operations in the most
profitable cost-effective manner
possible
we are a National Oil Company but retain
the commercial mindset and commitment to
efficiency of a multinational in fact
outside observers often see Saudi Aramco
as a company with commercial
sophistication technological
capabilities and market savvy and no
less than any other international oil
enterprise this tripod concept helps us
direct not only our existing business
portfolio and industrial activities but
has proven invaluable when it comes to
making investment decisions which in our
business really comes down to building
the next generation of the company since
the plants and facilities we are
building today will continue to be in
operation 30 or even 40 years from now
that's because the tripod itself
gives rise to a second concept that of
the golden quadrant
simply put we don't pursue each of the
of the three legs of the tripod in
isolation from one another
we look for the programs and investments
that contribute simultaneously I mean as
as much as possible to all the three
areas of responsibility for instance
when we look at a program a program
there's this multi-billion dollar
project on the table helped to enhance
our operational reliability and our
capacity to supply the market does it
benefit the kingdom and its society and
does it make good business sense over
the long term if the answer to all those
questions is a yes then it stands a good
chance to be in green lighted our recent
moves to integrate petrochemical
facilities with refining assets in the
kingdom are an excellent example of the
sort of golden Conrad program because
many of the petrochemical products that
will be produced will be exported these
facilities will help to meet rising
long-term global demand for
petrochemicals and goods and materials
made from from from them particularly in
the developing economies of the forest
these projects will also create good
jobs for Saudi nationals and because
they will form the hub of associated
industrial clusters and manufacturing
parks they provide tremendous
opportunity for the Saudi private sector
as well as international investors and
in terms of commonality these projects
enable us to add more value to the
kingdom's precious under carbon
resources and further leverage our
existing refining infrastructure put
another way they are when-when-when
projects and we are very very bullish on
their future prospects however there is
one additional area of responsibility
responsibilities which underlies this
tripod and that is our commitment to
protect and preserve the natural
environment which to my mind is one of
the most pressing and most complex
challenges the petrochemical industry
and indeed our planet faces at Saudi
Aramco you may not know this but at our
company we have had an environmental
policy in place since the 1960s long
before the environment became a major
concern and we have an excellent track
record of environmental stewardship
related to our facilities and our
operations now though we are also
engaged in a number of research and
development activities related to
environmental protection including
cleaner burning fuels digital forages
desulphurization of whole Croods and
refined products and next generation
engine technologies we are also closely
engaged in a number of carbon management
initiatives within the industry and
porton are closely with local and
international universities and research
institutes to conduct environmental
studies in fact last week as I told you
I was in China and Saudi Aramco was
presented by that forum was presented
the award for environmental stewardship
we served first committee that after we
this group met in Rio two years ago a
group was was formed and led by Saudi
Aramco so that all national companies
don't start from scratch to just
exchange ideas and if possible pull
resources so that really we can make a
different
another area is that in Saudi Arabia we
also have targeted children we are
working on on children and adolescents
there is a lot of teaching that as part
of our corporate social responsibility
to teach the children the importance of
the environment the importance of
keeping the proper environment the
importance of awareness of the dangers
that are that are facing us in the
future and one other thing Saudi Aramco
two years ago brought people from all
over the world for the first time we
brought experts on on carbon capture and
carbon carbon management from all over
the world and we had a three-day
conference to bring awareness to the
issues of climate change to our part of
the world we invited people from all
over the Middle East and we had people
from all over the world experts of all
just two so that we bring awareness we
keep to bring awareness to this issue
even though we are we are we are an oil
company we are not throwing this issue
under under the carpet we are really
putting it on the table and we are
talking about it and we are doing
hopefully a lot but with others at the
beginning of my remarks I told you that
by living these values and implementing
these concepts you could indeed change
the world for the better my conviction
is based not on a philosophical premise
or wishful thinking but on my first hand
experience with Saudi Aramco
as the largest and most reliable
supplier in what is arguably the most
important industry in the world we
believe Saudi Aramco's activities and
operations touch or influence virtually
every individual on the planet petroleum
is an enabling industry to every other
form of economic activity from industry
and manufacturing to agriculture and
infrastructure development healthcare
information technology and
telecommunications and of course
transportation oil and oil products help
to fuel entire countries and communities
power economic growth and development
and give a wide range of companies and
institutions the energy they need to
meet their old commitments as an oilman
I'm proud of that and in Saudi Aramco I
am proud of the degree to which my
company has contributed to that pool of
energy for generations but I am most
proud of the positive impact our
petroleum energy has had on individual
men and women the world over I take a
pride in the fact that this morning our
children could board a school bus fueled
by petroleum I take pride in the
pharmaceuticals and life-saving medical
equipment developed from petroleum
products in the fertilizers which helped
farmers earn livelihood and in the film
packaging and fuel used to wrap their
products and deliver it to our market
and our tables I am also proud that our
industry has helped and enabled people
to live safer healthier and more mobile
and more dynamic lives I believe that at
Saudi Aramco we have helped to change
the world one neighborhood one family
and one individual at a time through the
energy we provide people and my company
will tell you that we are in the
business of making people happy and that
is a business that I'm fortunate to
worked and for the last 40 years of my
life there is a gentleman as I prepare
to retire after a challenging and
rewarding career let me wish you every
success in your own career is regardless
of whatever sector of the economy
professional discipline or level in the
organization your path may lead you to
yours will be a different world of
business in many ways from the when my
generation has known but I believe the
sense of excitement the satisfaction and
purpose that comes with business
leadership will always remain constant
ultimately my friends the key to
realizing true success over your career
is always remembering that as a leader
you have both privileges and
responsibilities and never forgetting
that your primary mission is tied not
only to profits aring statements and
share prices but to making a positive
difference in the lives of your people
your companies and your stakeholders and
thereby changing the world for the
better thank you very much
mr. Jim aqua first thank you for flying
here it's a true pleasure to have you
share your experiences and knowledge we
really appreciate it especially at the
very last very end of your career to
make this real step we really appreciate
ur one of the questions that seemed to
be really of interest to a lot of people
is that the investor Matt Simmons wrote
the book Twyla and the desert has made
it has made a case for dwindling oil
supplies in Saudi Arabia based on the
advantage advanced drilling techniques
that Saudi used in its fields
why are your response to this
proposition and what are your views in
the notion of peak oil well with all due
respect matt is a is a fine gentleman I
I know him I meet with him and we talk
together but we came immediately when he
brought he was ready to to issue his
book we brought our experts to
Washington at the center foreign for
international strategic CSIS in
Washington and our people really just
explained that Matt came to Saudi Arabia
for a week he is not an earth scientist
in any way he's a financial man and
wrote a book what he said based on 200
papers that we presented those 200
papers we represented by our
professionals in professional societies
these are not secret papers these are
papers that are out and our people were
engaging others and let me just like in
the what mr. Seamon and on on Peak Oil
Peak Oil is a theory is a theory a
theory has certain assumptions and when
you change one of those assumptions you
can that theory can go you know the
theory is that you have a constant
amount of oil constant amount of
production no everything is being equal
in around you and altered
other sources of energy on really it has
been discredited but it's like looking
going back and looking at the file a
medical file of a child and says he had
fever when he was 2 he had measles at
the age of 5 he had broke his leg when
he was at 10 at 40 he has brain tumor
and so on and he says if we look at all
of those then he must be dead you know
the question is the question is if you
have if he had fever he was treated you
know but you know you look at one well
in the war that has 4,000 and 5,000
wills
and their will has a a problem and you
generalize okay I mean this is the
fallacy of composition they call it it
is you look at one minut area and then
Saudi Arabia I'll continue we have we
have consistently produced at in excess
of 3 billion barrels every year and we
have added to our reserves more than
that or equivalent to that every year so
we did not have to draw down our our
reserves technology is given is enabling
as to do a lot of things that we were
not doing a whole maybe some of our
people and upstream or here with you
they can sit with you and tell you how
we manage our reservoirs and so on
anyway to make a long story short that
theory is truly discredited if you ask
all the people in the industry they have
no problem they have they have no
problem that there is with our position
ok
but anyway next question thermal probe
thermal probe well to build on that
notion of peak oil has really moved the
world to really different areas and
being in this part of the world Silicon
Valley we see how determination to shape
the world towards renewable sources of
energy we see venture capital firms and
research institutions focusing
why are you abusing this shift and you
viewed it as a serious threat to the
Saudi economy absolutely not we are
encouraging the development if every
additional BTU that we can make we
should make it because the world will
need energy however what we what we
should think about is that fossil fuels
coal gas and oil fortunately or
unfortunately are gonna be with us for
the long haul
ok so we were we actually we are looking
at solar we are looking at wind
ourselves ok and we want to add if if
you for every thousand you a citizen you
have around 800 vehicles the Chinese
have only 20 or 30 vehicles for for
every every thousand so if the Chinese
were to go to the two to one quarter of
the level of the US okay you need a lot
of energy and and therefore you we need
all sorts of energy we encourage it cows
the new university is going to put a
concentration on solar energy and if you
think of solar resources there is no
place that has more standard Saudi
Arabia well that's good news for me at
least let me go to more political
question now we note especially during
the presidential campaign a large
movement pushing for US energy
independence as well as complaints about
US funds going to the unfriendly
countries and unfortunately Saudi has
been mentioned a few times as one of
these I'm friendly countries why our
views on this political rhetoric is a
short-term business the oil industry is
a very long-term
but my let me let me get down too there
is no such thing today of what we see
today of the of the economic situation
of the world there is no one who is
isolated so we are there is
interdependence and energy its and
dependent interdependence oil is a
fungible commodity ok it is if if the US
doesn't take it China is gonna take it
so it's one pool we are taking from the
same pool and of course if you if you if
you don't want it to an unfriendly
country like Saudi Arabia you can go to
your friend's and Venezuela I mean but
let me let me know seriously seriously
let me let me just get back what you pay
at the pump is not what gets into the
pockets of the Saudis what you get in
the path you refiners take it from Saudi
Arabia but then they ship it they put it
in pipelines they refine it they have a
huge business in the US that that part
of that of that of what you pay at the
pump is paying for bringing it to you in
in the US this is a whole industry but I
think what more important is the money
we get is not just money we spend for
not Saudi Aramco Saudi Arabia needs
funds for its this is we depend on oil
and therefore to have a stable Saudi
Arabia and have a stable income it's
very important for the world for the US
and for Saudi Arabia second is that what
I didn't talk about oil today but Saudi
Arabia is the only country that keeps
between one and a half to two million
barrels of extra capacity so that the
world doesn't see any hiccup in its in
its supply of energy we keep that at an
exorbitant price a lot of money and when
there were actually this capacity
stood many a time between world economic
peril and world economic prosperity and
in 19 in in 2003 2002 2003 that capacity
came handy to innovate our supply to the
u.s. from 1.5 million barrels per day
within four months to 2.2 million
barrels per day
we covered the problem Ximena tango from
the era Iran war we covered the
upheavals of the loss of Kuwait and Iraq
from in 1990 we covered during the 2003
war okay and we continue to do our
responsibilities the other thing is a
lot of this money comes back actually to
the US to buy equipment material
turbines to so that it can help for
energy security of the US if by a fair
wage if I buy a GE 20 or 30 GE turbines
and I take them to Saudi Arabia actually
they contribute to the energy security
of the US so the money doesn't go one
way a lot of it comes back by the way
you know and we get it we get a lot of
it also when we buy food and material
and we buy coffee of course you know and
a cup and a cup of coffee
you know costs $3 and a cup of oil cost
the board now you think that unforeseen
events such as the financial crisis wars
technology development or political
development would make Aramco become the
next General Motors or Lehman Brothers
know one thing I can tell you Saudi
Aramco we are the world's largest
producer of oil we have a capability
today of eleven million barrels per day
and we are raising it by next year to
twelve million barrels per day we are
producing much less now because of the
demand but I have no debt on my balance
sheet because all of my capital program
which is for five years is just under a
hundred billion dollars is is financed
from internally generated funds this is
very important so no we you don't see
Saudi Aramco we have the resources we
have that we have one quarter of roughly
one quarter of the world's proven
reserves but I think the most important
thing is that we really don't tap the
financial market for - to finance our
our projects only in our joint ventures
we have done but our program is totally
from a journalism method funds so we are
not the next Lehman Brothers what what
is your view on the role of various
governments in manipulating production
and thus influencing world prices of
well this is you are talking about Opik
I am NOT Opik I'm not I'm not going to
comment on I am a commercial company I
do get instructions from my government
as to what level of production but when
the price was at 140 we are arguing
there is no shortage in the market and
there is no shortage in the market today
okay
and I'm not going to defend what they
what they do when they pull oil from the
market
all it's because if the if the price
goes way down what you have is there is
no investment and in oil the problem is
it's not sufficient that you build a
facility and that's it if you build a
possibility to stay at where you are you
have to pump billions of dollars every
year to keep to keep producing and
therefore any the price is a price that
can give
producers time to develop that I mean
money to develop their economies but
also to give the companies enough money
to make the investment so that it
continues to it would we continue to
provide that barrel here we have been a
reliable supplier we have been put in we
are the country we are the country that
is in the last three years we have put
increments oil increments that are
equivalent to the production of
Venezuela okay and we keep a cushion of
roughly the production of Kuwait and the
Emirates you know these are major oil
producers we produce oil that is
equivalent to the daily production of
Shell Exxon Chevron and and British
Petroleum combined together okay and
therefore you need you need all I'm
saying is as the movement they do is so
that the price really doesn't go way
down where people will stop investment
by the way look what's gonna happen on
investment now in even when the price
have reached 50 when we were at 20 we
didn't think the price will go to 60
when we were at 140 we didn't think it
will come down but at 140 there was a
lot of oil in the market and our
customers are telling us they don't need
oil it's only political circles that are
talking about a shortage but the
refiners themselves we over oil and
Saudi Arabia put oil in the market and
said come and take it nope there are no
takers well we have like three minutes
left for the last question
thank you following up on on the issue
of the price as you pointed out there's
been a lot of speculation on oil futures
that has been fueling up the the price
of oil over the past few months there
has been calls in the u.s. to think of
commodities to rethink the market for
commodity futures I was wondering if you
could share some of your thoughts on
that concept no we have always we have
always said what brought the price and
it's clear now what brought the price to
140 or close to 150 was speculation in
the markets people were playing the
market and the king of Saudi Arabia the
custodian of Two Holy Mosques King
Abdullah when the price was reaching
around 120 130 he called for a
conference of producers and consumers to
tell them look you know the market is
we'll supplied the customers are saying
there is no shortage of oil there is
absolutely no reason for the price to go
to where it went and there was no change
in the market between the 140 and the 60
or 50 right now in terms of supply to
the market so yes I think I think any
regulation that will probably regulate
that you need you need a price discovery
mechanism and by the way I mean that
this we don't set the price ourselves we
don't set the price we talk our
customers and we say we'll look at what
it's traded in the market but that was
the most efficient way of finding a
price finding between us and the
customers that was acceptable to us and
to them and if there is any would be
great if Stanford would come and and
give us a a new method of price
discovery and not be subject to what's
happening in in the market we would love
to have that
this has been great again thank you so
much misogyny for coming here we really
appreciate